[Music]
the jury trial between technology
Powerhouse companies Oracle and Google
dubbed the copyright case of the century
and it really involved Google's copying
when a company is paying you tens of
millions per year if not hundreds of
millions it's probably a good idea to be
under good side but it looks like Oracle
didn't have this common sense as they
would go ahead and Sue Google in 2010.
if this was some sort of serious issue
like a breach of contract or unethical
practice this would have been completely
understandable but this related to a
petty copyright issue regarding an open
source programming language called Java
essentially Oracle was claiming that
while Java itself was free and open
source Google's use of java was
violating oracle's intellectual property
rights and the amount that Oracle was
trying to claim a disgusting 9 billion
at first you may be swayed to give
Oracle a chance because hey it's not
like Google is a saint themselves but
here's the thing this is not the first
time that Oracle has tried to form a
petty lawsuit ever since they started
acquiring other companies in the late
1990s and especially the 2000s Oracle
has shifted much of their focus to
quote-unquote protecting what they have
as opposed to creating real value in the
marketplace in fact Oracle has built up
a history of suing anything that moves
and they've become a dreaded patent
troll in most cases the companies that
patent trollsu simply give in and come
to some sort of settlement because they
don't want to waste more energy or
effort in actually defending themselves
but this was not the same case with the
Google for Google it wasn't even about
the money if it was they could have
easily settled in the early 2010s for
far less than nine billion dollars and
this would have likely been cheaper not
Dimension less stressful than waging an
11 year long battle against Oracle that
escalated to the Supreme Court but
Google had no other choice because
Oracle wasn't just targeting Google
Oracle was looking to set a president
that they could sue anyone for using
Java in a way that they didn't like also
if Oracle was able to set this type of
President it was just a matter of time
until other companies tried to set
similar presidents with their own
programming languages whether that be
typescript swift or c-sharp so Google
had to step up to the plate not just for
themselves but for the developer
Community as a whole so here's the story
of how Oracle should Google only to
regret it for the rest of their lives
foreign
can be traced back to early 2009 when
Oracle started trying to buy out Sun
Microsystems if you're not familiar with
sun Microsystems they were a tech giant
throughout the 1980s and 90s who did
everything from producing computer
hardware to developing programming
languages they were still massive in
moving into the 2000s but the.com crash
and subsequently the 2008 financial
crisis would have dragged down the
company substantially pretty soon Sun
started posting quarterly losses laying
off thousands of employees and running
out of cash normally such companies
would eventually just go bankrupt and
new up-and-coming companies would take
their place but sun was different while
their business was getting hammered they
still had a boatload of intellectual
property including Java as they were the
creators of java this made them a prime
acquisition Target and it didn't take
long for larger companies like IBM and
Oracle to become quite intrigued Oracle
would end up winning the bid for 7.4
billion dollars in April of 2009 and
pretty soon they had their hands on Sun
at first much of the media speculated
that this was a bold expansion strategy
for Oracle as this would be their first
step into Hardware while this was a
foreign territory for Oracle it also
made sense Oracle was already the go-to
software company for hundreds of
thousands of companies governments and
academic institutions so maybe they
could become the go-to hardware player
as well but from the very beginning
Larry Ellison the founder and CEO of
Oracle had his eyes on Java in fact he
even went as far as claiming that the
Java was the single most important
software asset that they had ever
acquired Sun CEO assumed that this was
because Java would allow Oracle to offer
enterprise Solutions and much cheaper
prices but Alison had a much less
honorable plan shortly after completing
the deal with son Ellison to turn around
and ended through Google over Android's
use of java but wait a minute why didn't
Google just get permission to use Java
in the first place well first of all
Java is an open source programming
language and the Oracle of rooms disk
themselves and one of their blog posts
and second of all Google actually did
ask for permission as soon as they
acquired Android in 2005. son wanted 30
to 50 million dollars in return for
letting Google officially use Java which
really wasn't a crazy ask Google wasn't
willing to pay this no problem but money
wasn't the only condition Sun wanted
Google to make all of their
implementations of java compatible with
the Java virtual machine and other Java
programs this was a deal breaker for
Google all Google wanted was a fork of
java that they could build upon but sun
was basically trying to get Google to
support a Java indefinitely to No
Surprise this deal would fall through
but Google would to move forward and
nonetheless after all Java is open
source so getting permission was really
just more of a courtesy son knew that
they couldn't reasonably challenge
Google so they just went about their day
but Oracle had other plans
Google went ahead and created their own
programming platform that was strongly
inspired by Java and they tailored it to
be used with mobile devices but wait a
minute what did Google even copy I mean
you can't just copy a programming
language itself right well that's right
you can't really copy a language itself
but you can copy things that are built
off that language in the case of Google
they copied Java's API packages if
you're not familiar with apis they're
basically just code that can be used to
establish communication between servers
and devices in a predefined manner for
example let's say you want this called
Twitter integration on your website you
could try to replicate Twitter's code
base or you could just call a Twitter
API and have this section appear
magically Java had dozens of such apis
that made their virtual machines and
programs substantially more accessible
to developers given that Google wanted
to make Android as easy and familiar as
Java development they not only copy the
37 Java apis but they also gave them the
same names we should note that they
created way more on their own as their
total Library would end up including 168
API packages not to mention much of the
implementation code was different as
well but nonetheless Google ended up
with 11 500 lines of copied code and
this would become the basis of oracle's
entire lawsuit the lawsuit would make
its way to the jury about a year and a
half after the lawsuit was filed at
first the jury had a bit of trouble
coming to a conclusion they established
that yes the limited Google had copied
portions of java the real question
though was whether this was covered by
fair use which was a much more difficult
question to answer but after seeing a
couple of presentations from Google
regarding how they modified and altered
Java the jury would have an easy time
siding with Google the final verdict was
that as long as this specific code
written to implement a method is
different anyone is free under the
Copyright Act to write his or her own
method to carry out exactly the same
functional or specification of any and
all method used in the Java API so you
would think that this was an open and
shut case right well no as Oracle would
of course appeal which escalated the
case to the federal circuit who looked
at the case from a completely different
perspective in early 2014. instead of
trying to determine whether or not
Google's use was fair this court decided
to focus on whether apis were
copyrightable and they would end up
ruining that oracle's API packages were
indeed a creative original and resembled
at taxonomy and therefore they were
copyrightable Google obviously couldn't
accept this so this time they would
appeal their argument was that the
copyright ability of java was irrelevant
the question should be whether or not
Google's use was fair and the second
district court would agree with Google
stance in 2016. just because Java was
copyrightable did it not mean that
Google infringed on said it copyright
now the ball was back in oracle's court
and they would of course appeal once
again which takes us to 2018. this time
the court would side with Oracle on the
basis that Google's use of a Java was
commercial and it does it was not
eligible to be covered by her use at
this point Google had to wins and the
Oracle headed to wins and there was only
one way to settle this debate once and
for all the Supreme Court
foreign
this was no longer just a battle between
two companies playing corporate games
this was a tech phenomenon as a win for
Oracle would Usher in an era of
restrictive development in fact this
battle was so Monumental that the entire
Tech world would get involved and they
would all rally behind Google this
included Microsoft Mozilla Red Hat Inc
IBM the computer and Communications
industry Association the internet
Association and even the Auto Care
Association we also saw 72 intellectual
property Scholars and the 93 computer
scientists throw their hats in for
Google meanwhile the only notable
organization that backed Oracle was the
Trump organization and I think the only
reason they supported Oracle was because
they wanted Oracle to play into their
Tick-Tock takeover plan so little to say
the cards were very much stacked against
Oracle and that this is very much how
the Supreme Court felt as well as they
would side with Google and a six to two
majority opinion the bottom line was
that copyright laws were created to
incentivize the progress of Science and
useful Arts the idea is that if
inventors are able to enjoy exclusive
Financial benefits for an extended
period of time they would be more likely
to invent great things but Oracle wasn't
trying to invent or progress they were
being patent trolls and preventing
further progress just so that they can
make even more money and therefore
Google's limited copying of the Java SC
application programming interface
constituted a fair use of that material
under copyright law we shouldn't note
however that Justice Clarence Thomas and
Samuel Alito dissented with the majority
they felt that by copying oracle's code
Google erased 97.5 percent of the value
of oracle's partnership with Amazon made
it tens of billions of dollars and
established its position as the owner of
the largest mobile operating system in
the world and it does Google should be
held accountable for damages but given
that six justices cited with Google that
ended up being the final verdict
so in the end Google came out on top
which was a massive win for developers
and the tech industry at large but even
if Oracle had won the legal battle it
would have still been a loss for Oracle
as a whole here's the thing companies
that don't pour billions of dollars into
programming languages and offer them for
free out of the goodness of their hearts
they do this to encourage adoption and
the popularity which will in turn give
them influence and control which can
then be monetized so creating a
programming language or any platform for
that matter is it very much a long-term
game but Oracle got caught up in the
short term and tried to milk Google for
fast profit and now they're gonna have
to pay for that indefinitely for obvious
reasons companies and developers will be
hesitant of working with Oracle because
they don't want to get caught up in a
Google situation and we can already see
the impact after holding the number one
spot in terms of popularity for over a
decade Java felt a number 3 and it's
likely that this trend will simply
continue as the sentiment is very much
turning against the Java also ants not
just oracle's programming business that
will suffer either companies would think
twice before doing any sort of business
with Oracle Google for instance is
slowly switching to sap and this seems
to be a larger industry-wide Trend and
given oracle's history you can't really
blame them and that's how Oracle smug
decision to sue Google destroyed their
reputation are you team Google or team
Oracle comment that down below also drop
a like if you're not a fan of patent
trolls and of course consider checking
out our Discord Community suggest with
the video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered
but until then I'm Hari Nazi guys on the
next one
foreign